well Pat was right Reince Priebus
Trump's chief of staff the next to be
fired in the midst of the constant chaos
endless scandals and one of the really
least functional White House's we've
seen in a very very long time it's not
even really clear what right did wrong
but generally you know things are
chaotic in the White House the chief of
staff takes the hit and Reince Priebus
took the hit it's not clear that Trump
and Ryan's had the best relationship I
read over the weekend that Trump once
had Reince Priebus come into the Oval
Office to try to kill a fly that was
flying around and bothering Trump not
really a sign of respect to Reince
Priebus Trump of course announced the
firing via Twitter I mean it's certain
where else would he do it at this point
tweeting over the weekend I am pleased
to inform you that I have just named
general secretary John F Kennedy is a
great American and a great leader both
of those terms capitalized great
American and great leader John has also
done a spectacular job at Homeland
Security he has been a true star of my
administration at this point what it
means to be a true star of trumps
administration is you haven't yet had to
resign Trump hasn't yet fired you and
you've mostly gone under the radar but
by not doing anything particularly
outrageous that makes you a star in the
Trump administration it's an interesting
move to I mean John Kelly as the chief
of staff he's not like he's a politician
or nothing and you know I'm sure he can
keep command of all the different staff
members in the White House but can you
really reach out to Congress and talk
about health care and tax policy and
infrastructure is hard to imagine and it
it a lot of this just plays directly
into Anthony scaramouche's hands right
he's the new White House communications
director who according to Sean Spicer
was the reason that press secretary Sean
Spicer quit recently and Priebus said
after the announcement that he had
always been super clear with Trump when
you think it's time for a new chief of
staff I would support it of course he
would he would have no choice but to
support it so several issues here one is
the one that Pat is alluding to hiring a
when you hire someone like another
former general you are putting more
military closer to the Oval Office
is a retired four-star general we
already thought Trump's Oval Office was
sort of military heavy and that is that
is growing right the proximity to Trump
of military advice continues to grow
that's one issue how exactly do Kelly
skills lead themselves to what a chief
of staff would a good chief of staff
sort of in the vein of Doug Stamper in
house of cards I'm sort of kidding
hopefully not killing people hope I
didn't spoil anything for you from
season one but in any case they're maybe
not season one but I'm getting off track
here
little bit yeah back to my point I don't
know exactly what skills Kelly brings
that are going to be useful as a chief
of staff but also this opens up because
he was homeland security secretary the
move of John Kelly from homeland
security secretary to chief of staff
opens up a slot for nomination and
Confirmation for homeland security
secretary which in itself might become
quite a show given what's going on with
the Trump White House right now and you
know one of the names being floated for
that position now Jeff Sessions because
that would be an easy way to settle by
both parties and end all of this
nonsense Wow
well let's not get ahead of ourselves
we'll see if that eventually happens the
other issue I want to mention is things
are great right now between Trump and
scaramouche II right there on the same
page previous out stop the leaks blah
blah blah when Trump and scaramouche II
stopped getting along it could
single-handedly implode the Oval Office
those two have the types of
personalities where if they no longer
are on the same page it will go nuclear
for lack of a better term and I
personally can't wait for that also
another tweet that we have for you here
regarding Donald Trump's prior
statements about chief of staff chief of
staff Donald Trump tweeting back in
January of 2012 three chief of staff's
which of course it's Chiefs of Staff
three chief of staff's in less than
three years
wouldn't it be fewer than three years of
being president part of the reason why
Barack Obama can't manage to pass his
agenda if ever that was representative
of what's going on right now
Trump unable to do anything amid
constant turnover and scandal among his
staff and cabinet
oh now he's on his second chief of staff
and only seven months so at that rate
that's going to be a much more turnover
than Obama ever had the one other thing
I want to mention here there's another
aspect to this Priebus was a mainline
establishment what I would call GOP Inc
Republican Priebus being gone means that
the mainstream Republican Party is more
and more separate from the Trump
administration the mainstream Republican
Party could have a more and more
difficult time having their views heard
by the Trump administration and it could
also mean that Republicans will
increasingly not be interested in
working with Trump or defending Trump
think about Priebus is out Spicer was
the former Republican RNC spokesperson I
believe he's out you bring in some
military people and Steve Bannon from
Breitbart and Anthony scaramouche II
from who knows what financial services
cesspool sessions is holding on for now
but Trump seems to want him out the next
step is an escalation with North Korea
and we're going to talk about that a
little bit later in the program but it
is not looking good for the Donald Trump
agenda the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership